forward march
ceremony of the keys is a typically
British tradition laid out here on the
Main Street of Gibraltar the historical
uniforms are a reminder that the rock
has been a British territory for over
300 years
Gibraltar was and is a strategically
important military base
Tito Viejo spent 30 years in the army
and so he still has access to the tunnel
system which stretches some 50
kilometres through the rock sometimes he
takes groups of visitors around this
subterranean military world the 68 year
old is proud to come from Gibraltar
I am NOT English I'm not Spanish
I am British developed alien you know
like the Scottish is Scottish British
and an Irish is Irish British we are
Gibraltarian British that is a lot of
that's something that Spain doesn't
understand to Spain we are all English
we are not English they call the Union
Jack the English flag is not the English
flag is the flag of Great Britain
Gibraltar has long been a bone of
contention Spain wants it back but
having both Britain and Spain in the EU
has served to reduce tensions between
the two countries still Vallejo is an EU
skeptic through and through Brussels
saying that now that we are brother
nations we should not have any borders
and that is there's where the danger
lies because Spain will see that as she
brought up being handed over to them as
being dissolved absorbs into Andalusia
to me that is what I I fear most
but that opinion is pretty much the
exception here the majority of the
33,000 residents are worried about a
possible brexit and there's an active
anti brexit campaign underway its
supporters believe the votes from
Gibraltar could tip the scales in the
referendum the campaign is focusing on
economic arguments to try to win over
the last remaining skeptics construction
law and financial services and I think
that should Britain vote to levy you my
job will be severely affected I can see
that there will be a downturn in the
Gibraltar economy and as a result you
know the the the economy that we've
worked so hard to build over the past 30
years will suffer commuters are used to
congestion at the border crossing but
this could just be a foretaste of what's
to come should Britain leave the EU
Spain has threatened to close the border
if that happens Madrid would seek to use
economic pressure to underline its
territorial claims but Tito Vallejo is
not worried about such threats
he's already experienced one blockade
when the then Spanish dictator Franco
blocked off the land route in 1969
overnight families were divided it was
effectively a siege designed to bring
economic hardship to Gibraltar
we've got the whole Commonwealth behind
us you know they think that we might not
need Europe don't wanna worry you got
the whole Commonwealth we've been we
still use the Commonwealth for many
things like meat butter and things like
that come from from New Zealand
Australia places like that so I mean
they were not close they're gonna suffer
again all these towns cities in aronia
will become ghost cities again and all
the people they will have to emigrate
in la linea the border city on the
Spanish side mayor Juan Franco has
enough worries already unemployment here
stands at 37 percent for this town
gibraltars strong economy is a lifeline
milk your chair every day up to eight
thousand residents cross the border from
La Linea to work in Gibraltar there's a
saying if there are clouds hanging over
Gibraltar La Linea gets a cold it's on
Noah Valley near sarahfey Tito Vallejo
remains optimistic
whatever happens you brought as famous
Barbary macaques are blissfully unaware
of all the goings on they will no doubt
continue to flourish whether their rock
remains in the EU or not
you